time for this week's pet project amy lee
joins us from the nspca
and today instead of talking about a
specific animal who needs to be adopted
we're talking about foster homes amy you
guys need more
foster parents for the pets right
absolutely hi kendall i hope you're
doing great you know we've got
so many people for the holidays and for
the summer and for vacation that's
covered restrictions are lifting
and we desperately need foster to help
us with the amount of animals that are
coming into the shelter every day
so what does that look like if someone
wants to foster a pet
how long are they going to have the
animal in their home
you know each commitment can vary with
you know depending on the animal you
know i've got a kitten here who actually
just came from a foster home and
um you know this kitten is going to be
ready for for adoption but you know we
get
we get single kittens that might need uh
to be in a home for at least a month or
so
until they're vaccinated and ready to be
adopted and are these pets that
uh have owners who are just gone for a
period of time or
there are also animals that are still
looking for a forever home
well typically right now with our foster
need it's for kittens so a lot of times
these kittens are found off the streets
so sometimes we get
boxes of kittens and we're just getting
inadequate
sometimes they're single kittens
sometimes they're full litters um you
know we can split up some of the litters
to have you know give you two or three
but those are the ones that we really
urgently need to care for sometimes
they're neonatal kittens which are very
very young
bob babies essentially but you know we
if you can foster if you've got a room
in your home that's quiet
you know you can just hang on to a sweet
little kitten or two
that would be really really tremendous
for us and you know that the process is
really easy
um the application is online so you just
visit us at nevadasvpc.org
fill out the online application and
somebody will be in touch with you
that's great so people can check that
out it might might be a nice way to
wade into pet ownership to see if it's
for you right
absolutely i think it gives you a little
taste of what it's like to be you know
either a cat mom or a dog mom sometimes
you know there's puppies that that
sometimes need home so
we really urgently are asking our
community to help us amy always good
talking to you
thank you if you're interested in
fostering or adopting a pet just go to
nevadaspca.org
or call them at that phone number
702-702-873-7722
las vegas now will be